i've often wondered if we should talk
and listen more with one another
not argue not yell at each other just
talk
and listen even if we disagree
jesse waters got his start in television
interviewing folks with whom he might
disagree
it will be fun to hear what he learned
what do you think about the state of the
nation right now oh my gosh i'm not even
thinking about that right now
i think we're kind of pissed off right
now she's doing right now that's a
longer discussion than a red carpet
would you vote for him
no i would not vote for him why not
because i'm a republican well he's a
republican
what year did we sign the declaration i
really i don't know
no 1964 1864 17
1776. we wanted to ask you why you
boycotted the inauguration
now you said that fox news chokes us and
lies to us
who's us and what are the lies
joining me now tonight is a former
production assistant at fox news and now
he's the host of waters world and the
co-host of the five
and now he's a best-selling author of a
great book how i
saved the world jesse waters how are you
i'm great after watching all my old
exploits i forgot how interesting i used
to be
well you're still interesting but what
what did you
learn about your fellow citizens or
about america conducting
these conversations on the street
i learned that i was in the bubble i
learned that
most people don't really care about
what's happening in washington d.c
they don't have a lot of respect for
politicians
and they're just living their lives
they're taking their kids to school
they're trying to make it to class on
time
and they only really care about a few
things the cost of living
and traffic and
basic things like going out to dinner
dating and perhaps school
or work everything else that you hear
about the infrastructure bill
you know those kind of things people's
eyes glaze over and they don't really
care
they don't really even understand the
difference between republicans and
democrats to a large extent
they just want their lives to be easier
and
cheaper and that's pretty much it
and that's a good lesson to learn for
folks that are in dc
and new york let me ask you this to me
it strikes me as
requiring a lot of self-confidence to
write a book
on saving the world and it requires a
lot of humility to put what you put
on the back of the book so first why did
you write a book about saving the world
and then we'll get to the back which i
find amazing what you put on the back
first
why'd you write it well i wrote it for
the money trey
because boy did i need the money and i
still don't think i was paid enough
because the book went to number one and
if i had to do it over again i would
have asked for more
but i had felt like i had gotten into a
place in my life where i had the time to
do this and i wanted to reflect on 20
years almost at fox
and tell these stories to the country
about
the news i'd covered the adventures i'd
been
on and what i'd learned from that what i
learned about myself
and about the american people and
uh what was the next question i already
forgot
well look i mean the stories in the book
are very very funny
but you instead of putting endorsements
on the back of the book put a
series of insults including
one person i think that said you were
shockingly ignorant which
i guess could be a compliment in a way
that she was surprised that you were
ignorant but
you didn't put endorsements you put
insults on the back
i didn't want to have to go on my knees
to hannity
asking for a blurb i didn't want to have
to owe sean anything
so i googled myself and first page is
all hate mail so we just slapped hate
mail on the back
soledad o'brien believes i'm shockingly
ignorant she said i mean really
shockingly ignorant
so i thought that was amusing and
brought me down to earth which as you
know trey
i need that well look jesse it's a
compliment that she was shocked
i mean that's the way i look at it it
wasn't like
you're boringly ignorant you're
shockingly
let me ask you this the most compelling
part
of your story to me is you literally
started about as low as you can start at
fox news
and now you are the host and the co-host
of fabulously
popular shows and you get you get to sit
next to dana perino so you started
making sure the caps were on
highlighters down in the basement
yeah and now you have two shows how did
that happen
i think it was a lot of luck i was in
the right
place at the right time and i was told
to do things and trey gowdy
obedience was very important whenever
anybody told me to do something i did it
right away
i was the first one to do it and i did
it as hard as i could
and and i did that for about 15 years
and now i get to sit next to
dana perino which in my book i've made
it
and i think the rest of the country
would agree with that
i think in all of our books you have
made it but speaking of books
your book made me laugh both the inside
uh
and the back this this mixture of
self-awareness and humility i think we
could use more of that
and uh so congratulations on having a
number one
new york times best-selling book in
addition to all the other things you've
accomplished
in life well thank you very much trey
and thank you for that great podcast
that we did together
one of my favorite interviews throughout
the book tour but i am jealous the trey
gowdy
graphics package is better than
wattersworld
how did that happen how did you get a
better graphics package than my show
i think they felt like i needed them
more that's why because
your content's so good they got to dress
me up somehow or not
stop thank you trey you're the best
thank you jesse
and thank you for spending part of your
sunday with us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else